doble menú para esta jornada con los
partidos entre Portugal y Marruecos
Inglaterra contra Francia para definir a
los otros dos semifinalistas de este
certamen por el lado de Portugal y
Marruecos los marroquíes una de las
sorpresas de esta copa quiere
convertirse en la primera Selección del
continente africano en avanzar hasta una
instancia de semifinales aquí juegan
arropadas por no solamente los
marroquíes sino también por la afición
árabe como lo reconoció su seleccionador
en la previa de este encuentro con el
conjunto africano las dudas son las
molestias que arrastran figuras claves
como su lateral estrella H Rafa aquí
mismo mediocentro Sofía o su delantero
no sé Siri además hay una duda en
concreto la de su defensa ayer quien se
retiró de esa Victoria contra España en
octavos de final por una lesión con
Portugal además de Las bajas confirmadas
ya en una Méndez y Danilo Pereira está
la duda sobre si finalmente su Central
Estrella Rubén día será inicialista el
detreno con todo el equipo por parte del
otro encuentro de Inglaterra contra
Francia Duelo con una rivalidad
histórica Los Galos que quieren retener
la copa obtenida en Rusia 2018 mientras
que los ingleses quieren llegar a
semifinales para buscar ese sueño de
volver a llevar el fútbol a casa como
hicieron en 1966 se espera la asistencia
de unos 8000 aficionados británicos para
este encuentro frente a la asistencia de
unos 4000 aficionados de